[Music]
hey you guys time once again for my
tomes of terror this is my little book
review series that i've been doing for
quite a while now
so as my previously stated love of the
novel's horror story and my best
friend's exorcism will attest
not to mention also the
amazing amazing non-fiction book which
is completely stellar and is beautiful
looking i own a copy it's called
paperbacks from hell and it's kind of
about the horror paperback boom of the
1970s and 1980s so all of that said
the author of all of these wonderful
wonderful works of literature is grady
hendrix and grady hendrix
has become in the last year year and a
half whenever i first started reading
his stuff easily one of my favorite
horror writers working today
he really does seem to have hit this
really kind of winning sweet spot in his
stories which kind of like he's it seems
like he's found like the perfect balance
between
humor and heart and
having like thought-provoking themes but
not being like real heavy-handed with it
and all of that interspersed with this
really brutal and very like
squirm-inducing like violence and gore
and stuff like that and all works really
well together this formula i mean if you
want to call it that sounds a little
dismissive but i mean it might not work
for everybody but i have to say that
every single thing of his that i've read
has just delighted the ever-loving [ __ ]
out of me and his 2020 novel which is
what we'll be discussing today the
southern book club's guide to slaying
vampires
is no exception matter of fact this
might be his best book that i've read so
far but i'm not sure because they're all
like really really good
now i may have mentioned once or twice
but i'm sure i've mentioned once or
twice before on this series among other
places that vampires aren't usually my
go-to horror sub-genre not my favorite
horror monster any of that i used to be
really into them like back in the 1980s
when anne rice was was a big thing
and i read all of those after a while
though the monster started to become a
little like stale for me
so i still do love a lot of vampire
media especially like from the old days
but i very very rarely seek it out on
purpose
and in fact you may remember i've had an
experience recently specifically when i
read uh brandon massey's novel dark
corner uh where i started to read the
book not knowing that it was about
vampires and then being kind of like
disappointed when i found out that it
was actually like about vampires and i'm
not saying that that's not a great book
because it was like i ended up really
enjoying it but i still like
didn't i went into it not knowing it was
vampires and then i was just kind of
like oh it's vampires you know what i
mean but then like i wanted to enjoy it
anyway but that said uh grady
hendricks's book tells you right in the
title that there's gonna be a vampire in
it so i wasn't like is blindsided i knew
what to expect going in or so i thought
the description of this book which is on
goodreads and amazon at other places
gives it a sort of elevator pitch uh it
likens it to sort of like this is like
dracula meets steel magnolias and or
fried green tomatoes
to an extent that's accurate but
please be aware
that if you kind of are expecting like
some like really funny cute like light
and fluffy tale
about like this gaggle of charming
proper southern belles kind of like
slaying vampires without dislodging
their church hats like in between sips
of sweet tea or whatever you kind of are
gonna have another thing coming the
story starts out kind of like that
but it does get pretty gnarly as it goes
on
um and actually ends up tackling a lot
of deeper issues than i was expecting i
guess i should have expected it because
i think i said maybe some of the same
things about my best friend's exorcism
um but yeah this kind of goes into some
stuff like you know rape child sexual
abuse um as well as a lot of like racism
sexism classism like going on in the
american south in the late 1980s um i
will note that there is kind of like a
dry sense of humor that kind of
permeates the whole book but it does get
into some really serious stuff and it is
like pretty
gory and stuff like that so if that's
not really your thing then you know you
might be kind of like surprised so the
story begins in 1988 in an affluent
suburb of charleston south carolina
and it's largely told from the
perspective of patricia campbell and she
is this housewife her husband carter is
a real successful psychiatrist he works
long hours and is rarely home maybe
because of work maybe because of some
other things never never really stated
explicitly uh the pair have two children
they have a teenage daughter named corey
and they have a son who i think is about
10 at the beginning of the story his
name's carter jr but he's pretty much
always referred to as blue
also living in the house is carter's
mother miss mary who's suffering from
alzheimer's and i guess like the thing
when she came down with alzheimer's and
couldn't live on her own anymore like
all of carter's siblings were like well
we can't take her blah blah so they
ended up kind of stuck with her and it
was terrible to say but you know she's
kind of like losing it so they have to
like take care of her she lives in like
this garage room now other than that uh
the campbell family as i said they're
very affluent they have a seemingly
idyllic life
but patricia is bored she kind of like
wants more out of her existence i guess
now she did once work as a nurse and she
seemed to find that very fulfilling but
when she got married she gave up her job
so that she could take care of the house
and the family and all that kind of
stuff now she's starting to feel like
after all this time
that maybe her contributions to the
family aren't really all that valued or
appreciated and she kind of wants some
excitement you know like uh you know
this is very she sees it as a very like
safe drab existence i mean it's just
constant cooking and cleaning and child
care and elderly care and you know
managing the household and everybody's
activities and all that kind of stuff
and she's kind of like sick of it
because it's like every day is sort of
like the same as every other
but because this is a very very proper
very southern very wealthy very
conservative suburb
there aren't really a lot of outlets for
somebody who's kind of like looking to
spice up her life in any type of way
so patricia does pretty much like the
only thing that maybe she could do in
this situation her and a handful of her
friends who were named grace kitty mary
ellen and slick
they put together a sort of like
loose book club or like a book club it's
not really a book club they just they
keep saying that now at first i think
that grace uh she's a very type a
go-getter no-nonsense kind of
personality
now she was the one that kind of like
started the book club uh and you know
the rest of them joined later on now her
whole thing was that she thought this
should be like um like an intellectual
exercise of some type so her idea was
well we have to read like all of these
like greats of western literature which
i'm not [ __ ] on that that's probably
like a noble goal but
the other ladies really aren't having it
it's like they they get part of the way
and to cry the beloved country and it's
just like boring them all the tears so
they're just kind of like jesus christ
can we please read something else uh so
they opt instead to start reading some
like really lurid like true crime like
you know truman capote like in cold
blood and rules the stranger beside me
which is about ted bundy if you haven't
read it um stuff like that so they start
reading that grace is not super super
happy with this situation uh but she
kind of like eventually gives in when
she sees that the book club meetings are
now like really lively as they all get
there and they're all discussing like
the latest murder book that they're
reading and what they would have done in
that situation and all this other kind
of stuff so it's like you know becoming
like really fun
uh the funny thing too is that they also
have to tell their husbands i don't
think they tell all the husbands just
some of the husbands that would
disapprove uh that this is actually a
bible study group because uh some of the
husbands would not approve of their
women folk uh reading this trash you
know what i mean so i thought that was
kind of like funny too so the first
let's call it a ripple in the deluge of
horror that is about to befall this
community
is when patricia is out in her side yard
like getting the garbage cans like tape
put on the curb or whatever and she gets
attacked by this elderly neighbor of
hers with the very apt name of ann
savage
now anne who just lives a few houses
down the street uh she has dementia
but it kind of seems like something else
might be going on either that or his or
her dementia has gone like way the [ __ ]
over the top because the woman basically
like jumps on her and she's like it's
pretty gross like this whole attack um
and she ends up
not only like scratching her scratching
patricia all up and everything like that
but it's like biting off her entire like
earlobe and swallowing it so there's
that
uh so the old woman gets carted off you
know obviously patricia has good
stitches and stuff like that the old
woman gets carted off to the hospital
and dies a couple of days later
now it turns out that shortly before
this attack anne's nephew a guy named
james harris
had come into town to stay in the house
to care for her
after anne dies patricia being a very
proper southern woman does the
neighborly thing uh this is what you do
when a family member dies is she takes
like some food or like a casserole or
some cookies or some [ __ ] like that so
she goes over there to take james
something to eat now when she gets there
she finds him in a kind of uh let's call
it like a very bizarre state that she's
not really sure what the deal is i don't
really want to spoil too much about it
let's just say that they get off on the
wrong foot okay it's just like kind of a
really weird situation so the following
evening uh james comes to her house and
you know profusely apologizes for
this whole misunderstanding and from
there it seems that a really nice
friendship begins to blossom between
patricia and james
james seems like very interesting uh
he's a lovely person he seems like a
nice dude now there are a couple of
strange things about him for example the
fact that he's like oh i lost my id
which isn't that weird but then he's
like well can you help me get another
one
um because she kind of knows everybody
in town like i said she knows like the
guy at the bank and all this other kind
of stuff also he has like this dirty
kind of like bag full of money like 85
000 and he said oh i found this in my
aunt's crawl space this must be her life
saving she didn't trust banks stuff like
that which he has kind of like a story
for everything right but there are kind
of like
things that maybe would be red flags but
patricia is just kind of like really
nice and really helpful so she's like oh
of course i'll help you get an id and
i'll help you open a bank account like
and put some of the money in and things
like that
and introduces him around to the
neighbors
and she also like opens her home to him
like he comes over for dinner all the
time because he's alone and the rest of
the family also find him a delight
especially the kids um and actually they
the kids like relate to him like better
than they do their own mom and dad in a
lot of ways uh and her husband carter
brings him in on this real big like real
estate development deal that all the men
in the neighborhood are working on and
you know they it promises to like make
them a whole bunch of money now
you know and i know that james is a
vampire
but obviously the characters in the
novel wouldn't jump to that conclusion
immediately as you wouldn't in real life
patricia really only begins to suspect
that something is maybe not entirely
kosher about their charming neighbor
when she hears through their cleaning
lady mrs green
that
little kids and teenagers in the black
part of town which is called six mile
have been disappearing uh turning up
dead or sometimes committing suicide
after some unexplained illness
and at each of these times uh people in
the community who are very distrustful
of strangers because of this stuff
that's been going on
have seen a white van now mrs green
actually wrote down a partial license
plate for this white van which she saw
at one time and it so happens that this
white van has the same partial license
plate as james harris's white van so as
the danger escalates patricia sees
some very messed up stuff with their own
eyes which again i don't want to spoil
but
the tension in the book and a lot of the
scares and terror in the book
it doesn't come from it's not like
suspense over trying to figure out who
the vampire is or like what or trying to
identify him because you know who the
vampire is like pretty much from the
second you meet the guy i mean you know
there's gonna be a vampire and this is a
stranger and all this weird [ __ ] starts
happening so obviously he's the vampire
but the suspense and the scary [ __ ]
comes from the fact that patricia and
even more so as it goes on
knows absolutely that james is a monster
but absolutely no one except for mrs
green
believes her even when patricia tries to
do the smart thing i mean obviously she
doesn't come right out and say you know
he's a vampire because everybody would
think it would be like some fright night
situation i just think you're a lunatic
but she tries to frame the whole
situation as oh he's selling drugs to
kids or he's a pedophile or something
like that
but even then like when she's not even
bringing in the whole vampire angle or
supernatural angle she's basically
perceived to be like losing her marbles
um her friends basically like largely
turn their backs on her uh her husband
who's a psychiatrist as i said tries to
put her on prozac he just absolutely
will not listen to anything she has to
say about james he even goes behind her
back and like sabotages her attempts to
like report james to the police
nobody wants to believe that this really
charismatic compassionate helpful and
let's not forget wealthy dude is
anything other than a totally stand-up
guy
and you know added to that is the fact
that nobody in this upscale neighborhood
wants to rock the boat and upset and you
know upset their like complacent
comfortable lives just because a few
kids in that part of town are dead like
it seems like it's not gonna affect them
right so the first part of the story uh
as i mentioned takes place in 1988 and
then after one particular event uh it
jumps ahead three years and i think it
actually ends up jumping ahead another
three years like as so it's from between
1988 to 1996 something or something
around there uh we get inside uh
patricia's head a great deal
and so we kind of learn how guilty she
feels about not being able to make
anyone listen to her about the threat
that james poses and then there's also
the question of her
you're questioning herself maybe i am
losing my maybe i didn't see what i
thought i saw you know what i mean so
she's always like second guessing
herself which you know very very uh very
common uh you know uh but finally like
as the story goes on with the help of
mrs green and eventually like the rest
of her book club she decides she's gonna
just go like damn the consequences and
try to rid the neighborhood of this dude
once and for all because he's become
very very dangerous so i have to say
this book was a blast i loved it uh it
was fun it was scary it was like super
entertaining and this was one of those
books like where i when i finished it i
was like really sad because i wanted it
to keep going you know what i mean like
i wanted i was like what happens then
what happens what happens now like what
happens with these characters i got like
so into it that i was like really bummed
out like when it ended because i just
wanted to keep going on i particularly
loved the main character patricia i want
to note here too that this is one of the
best examples because i think i've
talked before i think when i was talking
about uh richard layman and stuff like
that how sometimes it's like really
funny like how male characters like
right female uh you know or male authors
write female characters and like how
sometimes it's like really funny it's
like oh my god no woman would ever think
that but this is actually one of the
best examples of like a male writer
writing a female character that actually
seemed like a realistic character that
actually thought the things that you
know that someone like me would think
you know what i mean so you know props
there gotta say and one of the most
terrifying things for me i think was
just this feeling of
frustration that she had um because
she's being like constantly gaslated
like not only by her husband and by like
the other men in the neighborhood but
also like her own female friends who
just think she's like losing her mind
like she's lost her fragile hold on
sanity she actually thinks this guy is
is a predator um and they just
absolutely will not believe it and it's
just gets so frustrating like how like
having to like be inside of her head
like as everybody around her just like
turns against her kind of thing um it's
just really heart-wrenching especially
because you know she's right and you
know that like some really bad shit's
gonna i mean eventually you know the
shit's gonna come home to roost and it's
gonna come to like the rich neighborhood
and they're all gonna be like [ __ ] it
almost seems like there's not much she
can do about it because no one will
listen to her uh i have to say too that
the character of slick was also like a
big highlight and i say that because
in maybe another i don't you know i
don't want to like stay across the board
but her character is like a really
really hardcore like evangelical
christian i mean she's one of those
people like she believes halloween is of
the devil and there's satanists hiding
on every rock under every rock and stuff
like that which you know i grew up in
the south and around this era and you
know the struggle was real um some
people did actually like feel like this
but i feel like in lesser hands uh her
character could easily have become like
a caricature or
been kind of like loki like they were
making fun of her like she would be like
a figure of derision or something like
that in the story but she absolutely
isn't um her character is very complex
she's very fleshed out she ends up being
very honorable um and in the end like
quite heroic and i thought that was kind
of cool i mean all the characters are
but i liked her character like uh
specifically
i think one of the best things about
hendrix's writing or one of the things i
like best about his writing is that he
seems to have genuine sympathy for all
of his characters uh no matter how
flawed they may be and as i alluded to
earlier the story also kind of touches
on a lot of interesting themes without
being real heavy-handed about it um you
know obviously you have a theme of like
the sort of subtle and not so subtle uh
racism operating the american south in
this uh time period like i said just the
whole thing between this particular
neighborhood and that neighborhood and
like how they didn't really care about
it until it started happening to them
there was that um you know going along
with that the way the sort of affluent
like viewed the lower classes in general
the way being wealthy and charming can
kind of allow you to get away with
pretty much anything because everyone
will just take you at face value
um there's also sort of like the it kind
of tackles too the devaluing of the work
that housewives do like to keep their
families and households functioning uh
how it's just not seen as important and
just kind of like the belittling of
women's opinions and their interests in
general by certain types of dudes so you
kind of get into that but like i said
it's not really heavy-handed and it's
done with sort of like a dryly humorous
kind of tone to it so it's it's just
really enjoyable and kind of like droll
you know what i mean so i thought that
was like really really funny now keep in
mind if you are at all squeamish
please do not go into this thinking it's
gonna be
some little fun breezy it is fun but
don't think it's gonna be some little
breezy romp or anything
because this thing gets pretty
disgusting at times
uh especially if you weren't expecting
it to go like that
uh if you have a phobia of rats or
cockroaches in particular you might want
to stay far away from this because
there's a couple of scenes in this i
don't have i'm not afraid i don't have a
phobia about rats but even so there's a
scene in here that i was kind of like ew
and then there's a couple scenes in here
with cockroaches and i absolutely do
have a phobia about cockroaches and one
of them i was just like crawling out of
my skin oh it was so nasty but yeah so
actually there was two scenes like that
that did that because i do not like
cockroaches at all uh yeah so you might
want to stay far away or at least be you
know brace yourself for it uh there's
also i'm gonna say a pretty nasty uh
rape scene
and kind of like a pretty graphic like
description of the aftermath of it
uh there's some pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happening to children and teenagers uh
and there is a very graphic
dismemberment uh toward the end i did
see actually a few reviews on goodreads
from people who were kind of expecting
this book to be this like cute
light-hearted little comedy story
because of the title and the description
but then they were like shocked when the
gross [ __ ] started happening
so
if that's not your bag then just be
warned there is some really really nasty
[ __ ] in this it does have humor in it
but it is still a horror story with a
capital h horror so
just know that going in if you're
squeamish it does have some pretty
disgusting [ __ ] in it
so i'm gonna say as i probably said on
the other reviews that i've done of his
books i mean grady hendricks he's just
every single thing that i've read of his
i've re i've adored and i'm just like
looking forward to reading the rest of
his catalog i mean he's written like a
few more novels um i think he wrote one
called the final girl support group and
one called uh they sold their souls or
something like that and he's written a
lot of nonfiction as well um i've like i
said i've read one of his nonfiction
books which is paperbacks from hell
which is stellar i love it
um but yeah i'm definitely gonna get i'm
gonna try to like read the dude's whole
catalog because everything i've read of
his is just delightful and and amazing
and uh you know so let me know if you've
read any of his books i know that
they're quite popular in the horror
community and people do have differing
opinions on them so let me know if
you've read this or if it sounds good to
you like let me know in the comments and
we'll have a discussion about it and
that will do it for this tomes of terror
i will see you guys on the next one bye